Make this year's Easter eggs a work of art by learning how to marble them.
It's simple. You will need: hard-boiled eggs, food dye, vegetable oil,...
...containers, a spoon or dipper, and paper towels.
Step 1: Prepare the egg dye according to the package,...
...or make your own using natural food colorings.
If you plan to eat the eggs, make sure you use food grade dyes.
Step 2: Add a teaspoon of vegetable oil to each container of dye.
If you want to dye some eggs normally or give them a base color before marbling, do that first.
Once the oil is in the dye, you can't go back.
Step 3: Using a spoon or the dipper that comes with a kit,...
...lower the egg completely into the dye and remove it quickly.
Because oil and water don't mix, you'll get color on some parts of the egg and none on others,...
...creating a marbled effect.
Keep dipping to get a brighter color.
Step 4: Lightly pat the just dipped eggs with a paper towel or the color may become muddy.
If you want to dip them in another color, wait until they're completely dry first.
Experiment by adding a bit more oil to the dyes.
Different amounts create different amounts of marbling.
Step 5: Moisten a paper towel with vegetable oil...
...and lightly wipe down the finished eggs with it to add a nice shine.
Step 6: Refrigerate your eggs until you're ready to display them and wow everyone with your masterpiece.
Did you know? In 2005, Belgian chocolate maker, Guylian,...
...created a 27-foot, 3-inch tall, 4299-lb edible chocolate Easter egg...
...out of 50,000 praline chocolate bars.